this is election time obviously you know
last night 2000 you know november 3rd
results didn't come out
and they're both going to sue and
they're going to be in court for some
time
whether it's going to be this friday
next friday a month 60 days no one knows
what's going to happen doesn't look like
it's going to be a
very peaceful uh transition or no
transition it's just going to be issues
trying to recount everybody whatever
state trump loses he's going to want to
recount at whatever truth
states they lose they're going to want
to recount which one
do you think has the potential of
creating havoc
with riots and protesting if trump wins
or if biden wins and why
i think whoever wins we're going to see
violence and i'll give you my two
scenarios
say for example right now president
trump
gets the election all of a sudden all
these radical leftists are gonna
say that the election is illegitimate
and they're gonna start plotting
to try to take down the president just
like we saw in 2016 where they were
trying to disrupt the
the his inauguration by trying to use
uh um locks and and chains
to lock the the dc metro i mean that's
an act of terrorism and they were trying
to do that
luckily the fbi got involved and they
kind of they stop that
but they're gonna we're gonna see that
very soon
but at the very least president trump
will actually take action against
antifa so eventually we're gonna see
this kind of die down a little bit
because
a lot of them are going to go to jail
and rightfully unfortunately
joe biden will not take the same route i
mean he's the person who called antifa
just an idea
and he's soon going to realize that that
idea is also against him because they're
not against donald trump they're not his
allies
they're here to try to destroy american
society and i can't stress that enough
and if the problem though is if
president
hopefully not a president violent would
actually incite
the ire of the radical left
because every time something happens
where there's a case of questionable
police tactics or you know
sometimes things taken out of context i
mean
just a few days ago we saw something in
pennsylvania uh rather a couple weeks
ago
in which um it seemed like it was a
completely justified
shooting by the police and all of a
sudden everybody started writing so even
in cases like that
a president and hopefully not but a
president biden
would blame america and all these
liberals
who are on the fence with antifa they
would start seeing well
if antifa truly is systematically racist
then we have to take down america so he
will only spark
a allow more liberals to join
the radical left um very interesting
perspective to know that either way i
think the biggest thing is to know that
antifa is not
left it's not right it's not middle it's
so far
left that even an aoc is not on their
camp where aoc is seen as a capitalist
that's absolutely mind-boggling to be
thinking about that
now here's a question would you say the
same about blm or blm is slightly
different than antifa
so blm is definitely different i i will
say that there's
likely a lot of overlap but black lives
matter is still a marxist organization
but
um the interesting thing is that they
actually use a different tactics i
should actually
explain the two different tactics uh
antipa uses something that's known as
propaganda by the deed which is invented
by a french anarchist
and propaganda by the deed is a
political tactic in which you enact
political violence against your
opponents
in order to inspire others to take up
arms uh kind of like a call to arms kind
of if you will
and you see this time and time again
every time uh for example in
in a portland they would say come on we
need more we're getting away with it
we're taking down the police we need
more help
that's propaganda by the deed well the
black lives matter movement
uses a different tactic knows known as
the mass line the mass line was invented
by mao zedong
and it is the reason why china today is
a communist country
the purpose of the mass line is to
infiltrate honest movements
and inject them with a dose of marxism
so
everything that uh is wrong in the world
is because of the is
the fault of capitalism and black lives
matter is supposed to be
a movement to stop police brutality okay
well when you look at their objectives
up until very recently right before the
election
it was to destroy the the nuclear family
well that's a marxist belief and that's
what they're doing they're trying to
sugarcoat marxist beliefs into
palatable statements that every american
can swallow and i mean everybody
a few months ago uh founders of the
black lives matter movement said oh like
you know we have an ideological
framework we're trained
organizers we're trained marxists and
there was a lot of conservatives who
rightfully said ah see we told you
they're actually marxists but a lot of
people missed
the phrase right before that we're
trained
organizers well trained in what
they're trained to organize under the
mass
line so while there's is a lot of uh
they do use different tactics though
there is a lot of overlap because both
of them are radical leftist activists
and it does it would not surprise me if
a lot of the leaders from like
uh the black lives matter movement also
put on the black mass from time to time
even though at the ground level
there are a lot of black lives matter
protesters who
they don't understand that they're they
belong to a movement that is a radical
leftist movement
that is not seeking to end police
brutality but to
end the capitalist system as a whole are
you noticing this tension create an
opposition because you got a couple
other groups coming out on the complete
opposite side boogalo boys
uh which is led by a you know 22 23 year
old former marine and patriot prayer
are you seeing the opposition also
create a group like to oppose them
yeah and i actually argue that it's
actually pretty dangerous because
uh every time that i hear some of the
some of the things that the chance that
they say they say oh it's time to take
back our streets from antifa
and it could it's one thing that antifa
is actually creating chaos but at the
same time i think it's dangerous for
private groups
to try to meet antifa on the streets
because
what happens when say i know the bugle
boys
show up and they beat up antifa and tifa
doesn't go away
they go back home and then they recruit
more people and what happens when antifa
comes back even stronger and they beat
up the boogaloo voice
well all of a sudden that's a call to
action for them and then you just have a
cycle of violence in which
uh both groups feed on one another um
and
ultimately uh we have to put pressure
on our governmental institutions of the
police and elected officials
to crack down on antifa because private
action against antifa will only make
things worse